What made Emily Blunt cry on the set of Edge of
Tomorrow — and what was up with
Tom Cruise's brutal response?
"This is where I come to cry"
The 2014 action epic Edge of Tomorrow may
have been one of the best sci-fi movies
of the last decade, but it's one that
star Emily Blunt might want to forget.
Set around Blunt and Hollywood legend Tom
Cruise's futuristic soldiers, Edge of Tomorrow
is a time-loop tale about fate and redemption,
one which sees humanity waging a war against an
alien super-organism known as the Omega. During
the opening battle, however, Cruise's character
manages to kill one of the Omega's drones and
somehow co-opts their ability to loop time.
In order to defeat the movie's alien invaders,
Edge of Tomorrow's human soldiers are equipped
with armored ExoSuits, which were built from
scratch by director Doug Liman's production
team and weighed nearly 100 pounds. According
to Blunt, filming Edge of Tomorrow inside the
super-heavy ExoSuits was one of the most grueling
tasks she's ever faced in Hollywood — to the point
where she broke down crying in front of Tom
Cruise on the very first day of test shoots.
"And?"
"It's a cold hard world, s--t happens."
On an episode of the
"SmartLess" podcast, she said:
"The first time I put it
on, I just started to cry,
started to cry, in front of Tom,
and he didn't know what to do."
Production designer Oliver Scholl and costume
designer Kate Hawley were responsible for creating
the ExoSuits. Doug Liman wanted a "simplified
and raw" look to them, and a team of handlers
had to be used to get the suits on each actor
every day. For Cruise, specifically, it took
around 30 minutes just to get inside his suit when
testing first started — and another 30 minutes to
get out. By the time the shoot began, though,
Cruise had cut the time down to 30 seconds.
"Where's your helmet?"
"Never wear one."
While the actor viewed the ExoSuits
as an on-set challenge, however,
Blunt saw them more as an unbearable
nuisance, which prompted Cruise to give
her some harsh advice. When it came time
for Blunt to begin test shoots with Tom
Cruise — and the tears started flowing
— Cruise apparently didn't hold back.
"He stared at me for a long
time, not knowing what to do,
and he goes, 'Come on, stop
being such a p***y, okay?'"
According to Blunt, the comment was laughed off,
(Tom Cruise laughing)
and things were reportedly fine between
the two actors throughout the rest of the
shoot. But that didn't make things
any easier on Cruise's co-star.
"I had to do this aerial stunt on wires,
and I was supposed to land on my
shoulder, "And I landed on my face."
Despite everything, Blunt was reportedly on
board to film an Edge of Tomorrow sequel in 2019,
but the plans were eventually scrapped.
She told Entertainment Weekly in 2021: